[Music]
Trauma occurs in many forms, ranging
from verbal to physical and our sexual.
Whether you've personally experienced abuse
or have witnessed it, we want you to know
that it's not your fault nor are you alone.
Not only is it hard to talk about, but it
follows you even after it's over.
We hope wherever you are today that you're
in a safer place.
Our hearts go out to anyone who's been a victim
of childhood abuse.
In our description box below, we've included
a few hotlines in case you need to contact
someone for help.
As always, you can also reach out in the comment
box.
Here are 7 ways childhood trauma follows you
into adulthood.
1: You can't seem to remember much of your
younger years at all.
Do your high school years feel like a blur?
You might find yourself drawing a blank when
someone brings up a childhood memory and you
can't recall the same one.
People with childhood trauma may experience
flashbulb memories in which they remember
vivid moments but not the full event.
When you look back on the past, it's made
up of more black holes than fully written
chapters.
You might even feel like someone or something
has stolen your childhood depending on the
severity of the events.
2: You find yourself in toxic relationships.
If you've ever watched or read "The Perks of
Being a Wallflower", you'd be familiar with
the quote "we accept the love we think we
deserve".
When you grow up in a household devoid of
love and emotional support, healthy relationships
are a foreign concept to you.
In fact, many people who face childhood trauma
often adopt the fearful avoidant attachment
style, where they want emotionally close relationships
but find it hard to trust or depend on others
completely.
Consequently, without knowing it, you might
seek destructive relationships, mistaking
the mistreatment and uncertainty for excitement.
3: Or you feel like you don't deserve love
at all.
People who experienced abuse in their childhoods
might avoid romantic relationships altogether
believing they can't be loved by others.
This is known as the anxious preoccupied attachment
where the individual wants to establish emotional
intimacy with others but often fears rejection.
As a result, vulnerability is usually avoided
when they've only been hurt by people they
once trusted.
This kind of trauma doesn't just ache, it
ruins you.
4: You develop passive aggressiveness.
Did you grow up in a household with anger
all the time?
It can be so scarring that you might even
grow fearful of this emotion.
You learned at a young age that none of your
emotional needs were important, so you've
only resorted to buring or suppressing them.
As you reach adulthood, you'll continue to
exercise passive aggressive behavior because
straightforward communication was avoided
when you were a child.
5: Negative self-talk is amplified.
Childhood trauma gets into victims heads and
makes them believe they won't ever be good
enough.
It's not something they can just snap out
of or fix with positivity.
It's scary and real how convincing their parents
might have been when their words and actions
cut them deep.
6: You ride an emotional roller coaster.
You might either feel too much or not enough
at all.
Trauma can cause a disruption in your emotional
well-being.
Signs include trouble making decisions, impulsive
behavior and random outbursts of anger or
frustration.
7: You don't know who you are.
Identity is difficult, but it seems more impossible
to grasp or pin down when you face childhood
trauma.
Its slippery like a fish and the more you
try to see yourself, the less you begin to
recognize who you thought you were.
Have you or anyone you know experienced any
of these symptoms?
Please share your thoughts with us below.
We're an open-minded team and we will never
judge you for your stories.
In fact, we often find them inspiring.
Also don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more helpful tips and share this video
with others.
Thanks so much for watching!